- When I was 26 years old, I
began losing a lot of hair.
(gentle music)
It was terrifying.
But I wouldn't change a thing
about how everything has unfolded.
My name is Anthony Carrigan.
I'm an actor, and I have alopecia.
Alopecia areata, is a, it's
an autoimmune disorder
in which your body thinks that
something's wrong with it,
and so it attacks the hair follicles,
and because of that you
lose patches of hair.
I was very shy as a kid.
When I first started acting,
I began to kind of discover
this voice within myself.
So when I lost a lot of my
hair, I had no idea what to do.
I didn't know if I
could still be an actor.
I didn't know if I could
remain in this business
that was so, so image-focused.
But then I found something within me
that was worth fighting for.
I found a whole new perspective
on the way that I looked.
I found a whole new perspective on
what kind of characters I could play,
and I began to cultivate that.
I have been typecast as the villain.
I think it isn't just me.
Bald guys throughout history
have played the villain.
Some of the TV shows that I've been in,
I was on an episode of The Blacklist,
The Flash on the CW, and Gotham on FOX.
For the longest time I tried
to kind of create a certain self
that didn't have alopecia,
because a lot of the time we feel
like we need to put on a face,
and that's just not real.
It's all about being human
and it being okay to not be perfect.
(upbeat music)